Sauna lovers praise the health benefits of "sweat baths."
They say saunas prevent sickness,...
...help heal and clean one's body.
The sauna of Finland is a tradition that is more than two thousand years old.
The Finns claim they live a long time because of their sauna tradition.
Basically, what happens to the body during a sauna is quite simple.
Your body uses its energy more quickly,...
...your heart rate speeds up...
...and your blood vessels become much more flexible.
Your hands and feet also benefit from your blood moving around your body faster.
This also happens during exercise,...
...but using the sauna is more fun and you can do it while relaxing.
Lovers of dry heat baths say they feel at peace while in the sauna.
They claim that the sauna takes away cold symptoms,...
...revives the muscles after tough exercise and clears the skin.
The sauna experience leaves you feeling very much alive...
...and with all your senses sharpened.
The sauna really helps your mental health!
The sauna's healing powers help to rid the mind of depression and anxiety.
After leaving the sauna,...
...the mind is in a relaxed, clear state and free of worries.
This is because when the body feels soothed and energized,...
...the mind and emotions usually follow.
So when you are feeling stressed,...
...head for the nearest health club, spa or jimjilbang.